[Music]
all right hi guys welcome to today's
lecture about and games in the endgame
so for today I prepared some interesting
and games that I've seen lately one guy
one I mean SF snatch the few days ago
and one from my own game which I'm not
sure whether we will have enough time to
cover both hopefully we will so much
does not waste time waste and just get
into discussing both positions we've in
general about complex and games with
many pieces and you know what can happen
there there theoretically so in normal
games so the first game I want to talk
about is diplomacy
versus maxima Sheila graph from chess
table masters not from today but two
days before two days ago
so in this disposition it was this
position and if we look at it initially
basically positions around equal right
like there is no any reason for why
white or black blue better black has
pair of bishops true but the white has
been pawn structure pawn pawns d5 and d4
are pretty weak also upon b5 could be a
weakness however there is no easy way to
kind of take you know make take
advantage of that the pawns on b5 s are
opposed on HCG v are pretty advanced
it's possible that some HR g4 maybe it
may become coming in especially the
Queen's on the board it is definitely
not an easy
you know it's not easy for why to expose
weaknesses so in this position any
partnership played Queen f3 which is a
very good move and I believe that mvl is
simply in around this position see
starting with these positions of my
several inaccuracies that led him on the
verge of defeat basically and in a very
sort of solid way like knew you wouldn't
expect that to how to happen so let's
see what happened right now first minor
mistake we Tex Avery he traded Queens
and this is the angle I want to talk
about so for us it's good that he played
it because we can have some interest in
here to talk about but in general
objectively who have played of here
before he should have keep her kept
crews on the board in the sequin ate
kimchi seven ideas rh5 maybe h5 h4 h5 g
4 it's not simple for for--why to do
anything here I'm not saying that black
is better because black is not better
position so it was around equal I can
play for instance I don't know derm I
possibly G free is good if B should take
is frequent a is d5 so and if h5 there
is move just Kinney g2 and you know
positions around equal however you know
maybe wide little bit a little bit
preferable because it seems like this
pawn this structure with the divide the
four points it seems like white has some
two may have some chances here but over
another after age four five six
pollution is just just around equal so
this was the best what mvl should have
played instead in this position after
Queen Fe he took and route takes a three
age five he played move age five and in
this position you need to ask yourself
what is the essential thing right now
for for black to do and then you will
realize that pawns be 55 d4 are weak and
they could be sort of object of the
attack in the few
and in order to prevent that from
happening in order to improve their
let's say position and make sure that
they are not gonna fall black King has
to join the game on the Queen side
ideally two king should go to the six or
c5 squares and therefore I believe that
the best move right now was King g7 and
King D 6 King c5 later as we will see in
the game basically and we managed to
bring his King to the king the Queen
side and anyway and the game ended in a
draw however I feel Emily I don't think
there are any serious issues for for
black the idea is that if the King comes
to c5 that or disease or c5 then why
black rook can be freed from the
defending the b5 pawn and can join the
let's say King side and try to you know
create some counter play on the King
side using the pair of bishops so for
instance analyze qg4 Kingi six rook e8
let's say activating the rook but just
king c5 and there is nothing that
actually what I'll see at least of all
the white can do for instance cooking
the 36 even rook c8 with trading rooks
after after let's say I know 92 for
instance trying to mine I have an IG
free and stuff like this
there is rook c8 I don't see anything
here for white position is just around
equal was importantly the rook is freed
from defining this b5 pawn and after the
King we joined the Queen side so this is
very important instead and we all played
again labels about to move some optimum
of he played move h5
right now it's still nothing bad they
stole nothing terrible position still
around equal rook a8
irrigate still King g7 is possible there
is nothing wrong move it and HR educates
afraid of g4 so white has to react to
this somehow and he played only an apple
played King of 1 which is a good model
because it prepares this idea Alice I
even three for the 91 92 and I will come
to a Foursquare it should be generally
good for for what but right now it was
final moment for VL
realize that he has to bring his King
here King g7 again King 1765 is just as
we discussed earlier is just equal
basically in M games Kings activity is
very important and King Khan c5 is does
lots of functions is very active
most importantly the defensive functions
right now but anyway is much better than
passive King on the back rank or let's
say on somewhere on the King side where
doesn't do really anything
therefore the skin d7 was the best move
right now instead I could move Ruby 8
and after OB 8 suddenly is not so easy
for black anymore because right now very
strong move by nappa rook a7 Roop cuts
the King on the seventh rank and it is
not right now possible to bring the
skink easily to the to the Queen side if
the King doesn't come to the Queen side
black robe is forced to be defining this
bit b5 point passively black cannot
activate the rook and basically if you
pay attention to black's pieces right
now rogue is defending this pawn to b5
pawn bishop is defending d5 pawn and
Bishop f6
is defending deportment almost ball back
piece are forced to basically defense
instead if the King would come to c5
pawn kill King will be defending all
those pawns and black pieces could be
activated pretty simple and
straightforward so in this position and
we applied the tiebreaking g7 trying to
maybe activate his scheme through the
King side but as we will see it doesn't
work right now very nice move by nappa
night g1 willingly going back going away
from this F 3 square but improving it
let's say maybe to eat to at some point
and most importantly the knight doesn't
go under the same time under g4 Tempest
so very nice idea trying to improved it
to in trying to improve it maybe to the
King side maybe to the Queen side maybe
for c1 a2 to before sometimes could be
some ideas like this put some pressure
on the d5 pawn basically just put some
arrows 92-91 i did to night before could
be an idea also could
to provoke weakening of f4 square by
playing by Freud by forcing let's say at
some point in g4 and then that can also
go to f4 it could be possible as an idea
in general a g1 is the way to go here
for white and Bishop e5 happened they
repeat it like once the position and but
in general in this position again you
need to ask yourself what to do here
with with black because if you just stay
in place white we'll slowly improve the
position and it is black who is
definitely under pressure because of the
bad pawn structure and worse less active
pieces so in this position it was again
very important to bring this King to the
Queen side of course it's not as great
already as it could have been done
before because the scheme is already on
g7 why already made some moves while
made some progress but the skin was the
queen size simply belongs so the path to
do it was to play Bishop d8 right now
Bishop d8 and idea is to play Bishop d6
keep the stroke out of the seventh rank
and then bring the skink for f6 to e7 or
fa fi 27 and 36 ideally to c5 so for
instance g3 analyzed we should be six
kicking out the rook rook a6 king of six
King G to King g7 King is already much
better place when he certainly was on g7
right
so if Knight f3 it is possible to play
d4 Knight g1 and King D 6 9 H 4 in order
to fix the spawn structure King C 592
Bishop c8 ok one in Bishop c7 it's one
of the example lines is there over there
were of course alternatives for both
sides however I think this is a pretty
good example of what should have been
already now the best defense by by black
and the best let's say attempt to play
for a winnable fight we will cut it with
him coming to this position and as we
will compare in a moment this is much
better version of what was what happened
in the game because kilo c5 is actually
covering the entire Queen side all those
weaknesses be fired
before are covered they are not being
attacked right now by I mean attack only
ones with by night and pound if 24 by
once by night on it and 25 by Bishop on
be free opportunity five covers a
dilatory of them and right now if the
black and black Bishop can come to e6
it will cover also d5 there is no really
easy path for white to to create any
kind of you know danger for for black I
didn't analyze it further because it's
kind of you know I want to focus on the
game but here I I would assume that the
best path for Y to try to get something
is to bring the King to the center and
then play move c3 this I and then try to
play something like this of course it is
very close to equality still however I
prefer white anyway this was the path to
go for for black so in this position mvl
played Bishop e5 probably not
understanding or realizing the danger
that actually exists in this position
we should we have happened rook a6 and
this is a good move because maybe and we
all want to play King f6 started try to
bring the skin Bluetooth for the 36
right somewhere there but after Luke a 6
a king f6 is meant by a bishop 65 of
obviously just to show it quickly this
would be the big problem so he can he
can do it anymore the question what to
do next
right now trying to bring this bishop
for a 7 through c7 to be 6 doesn't work
because after Bishop c7 Knight f3 both
both pawns are under attack and white
wins one of them so this is bad for
black king of C doesn't work as we
discussed and MV up try your plate right
now g4 and this is another mistake that
he did because right now after H for
this is this position is similar to what
we discussed earlier with this pawn on
h5 this move h4 basically fixes the pump
on h5 which is right now potential
weakness
and and it's not easy to get rid of this
weakness instead in this position and we
also played h4 and this is I believe the
best defense by black the idea is maybe
it's in the future played g4 simplify
the position trade some pounds on the
kingside and most importantly this move
doesn't create any weaknesses it
provokes some simplifications in the
future which as a defensive side right
now because right now there is no doubt
that wide lags on the defensive side
after not bring the kink initially to
the Kings side is the Queen side so
black needs to be sort of careful not to
get really like greed unpleasant
position and h4 was the way to go
because I think the right now is g4
could be an idea and it's after 93
Bishop f6 nothing wrong with it
do you know again the idea could be at
some point to play g4 of course isn't
possible yet but let's say if I can
let's say for instance analyze King g1
maybe room p7 sort of little bit waiting
for now but also already g4 right now
could be interesting the thing is that
if in this position before is not quite
as not quite work because after g4 takes
takes which would takes d5 and if rook
c8 there could be some issues with Ruby
7 and hitting-point on f7 while we play
that first rugby 7 King H 2 and now g4
is already quite possible because after
this days this rook c7 we are tagging c2
and we have enough counter play let's
say we should be free we can think about
already about trading on a free and this
opposite color Bishop endgame is not is
unlikely quite dangerous for black but
also we can play for initiative and pie
and conversation with Ruby 7 Ruby -
let's say this this and we now do it and
now we play we should be 5 Bishop f4 and
I don't really think that there are any
real problems here for fro black black
should be able to comfortably hold it
because also H pawn is it's a passed
pawn can create some counter play so I
don't think that there are any real
problems for black it was still hovered
white position slightly better however
so in the end hold it this was the best
defense h4 however you know early we
have to give the pawn it becomes in it
means that something went wrong on the
way and g4 is other mistake by MVL after
h4 rhino punished h5 is fixed and this
night
a has potential to go to f4 and attack
this h5 point in the game happened right
now Bishop c8 of course b7 is still not
good
trying to play Bishop b6 and bring the
king because already there is a
Foursquare so after 92 we should be 694
and this is already very bad for for
black because pond if I was hanging upon
h5 is hanging simply lost so Bishop c8
played and VL Luke a7 Bishop e6 trying
to wait in place no you know what to do
next
now you're talking f6 and now g3 and
this position suddenly is extremely
dangerous for for block I think that
with best play it's possibly winning for
white already I am making this claim
very kind of carefully and cautiously
because I don't want to just claim that
it's winning but I would say that with
best play black-white should win it
because it's just at least from
practical perspective because it's such
so hard to make defensive moves here
with black that I'm not sure whether
it's possible basically so in this
position there i considered two moves
and we applied room b6 which i think is
the best practical try and we'll see in
a moment why I just want to see so
quickly basically it's active defense
rugby 6 however you know may not seem
less active defensively black has no
active defense indeed this is a active
defense and we'll see why in a moment
the thing is that if black tries passive
defense King g7 the white has very
simple plan to follow and white can
black can prevent that and it simply
game over so right now if bishop a to
rook c8 and
see - is hanging we have to come back we
should be free it is not what we want
therefore we play at first kinky one
King do you want let's say black waste
king of six now Bishop a - makes perfect
sense because Roxy is made by King D -
after the second g7 rugae six may be
preventing king of season if you
checking in certain lights and black
weights and right now white plays before
and again but before we are fixing B 5
pound as a weakness King g7 we should be
freaking h7 King f1 right now King that
has done his job it doesn't go to D - he
was going to D - only temporarily to
prevent Roxy lq Roxy - Rena King comes
back King f1 King g7 and right now it's
time to go neither for neither for a
pawn takes and let's save the King goes
there it with five which is go King G
free and in this position is simply
winning for white black has lots of
weaknesses pawn before is a fixed
weakness pawn on d5 the weakness as well
Paul on h5 is also a potential weakness
that it's you know object of whites
attack and the most important thing it's
sort of a Dukes funk also for black
right now because if the route goes to
b7 white ghost rook to white rope goes
to a eight and there is possible rook h8
or Ruby g8 and trying to attack from the
opponent h5 also the restroom d6 idea
so if ruby theatres Ruby six possible
simply blacks position is just
collapsing and then why do we need it
before to put let's say
Bishop a2 and then before because in the
if we do it immediately if we played
Knight f4 immediately in this position
let's say after King g7 we play then
move rather than either for it that's
why it's so important in end games this
role do not hurry because in this
position let's say I don't want to cause
confusion right now so yeah the King f6
that side is our new king of seize it
rook b6 for instance kimchi - kimchi 6
kimchi free suddenly can black and play
rook c6 and this rock goes to C 5 square
and it's not easy to kick this rock out
and suddenly however weirdest
seems I didn't find a clear path for a
white to improve the room on c5 cause
both witnesses did b5 and d5 and
whenever this group comes from the back
Ryback rank with Ruby eight f6 let's say
loogie I came Bishop f7 for instance and
again I don't see really a follow-up to
what what they worried about toward what
is doing there could be some ideas
obviously but to be honest I don't see
anything special so that's why it's
important to play before here at first
after King g7 try to bring this poem to
before as the main line goes and then we
should be free because we take this a
five squared from the rock and then all
all those ideas work for white but Ruby
six is a very interesting defensive idea
and here I would continue our personally
of my suggestion would be here to just
continue King he won King D to play a
probably a two before and so on with the
line we just discussed let's say this
king did too
imported liking we do not King D one
because after King D one it's not so
simple because of oxy seven and after
rook a eight there could be kinky seven
and the idea is that if sorry not here
not true gate a six if King g7 rugby six
trying to attack b5 phone suddenly black
has lots of counter play Brooke movie or
a seven idea is took a one if Bishop
rook text b5 rooked Rock a one track
King D - and the rook F 1 if Knight c1
our night is very passive a creative
Bishop g7 Bishop h6 which is definitely
in Black's favor therefore is important
to play king d2 that we don't run under
this track on on the on a back our back
rank so after King D - let's say 47 Luke
a6
kingi 7 room B 6 black rook has to go to
the passive defense and let's say Bishop
a2 before it's our stoppable why this
new winning or nearly winning basically
it's extremely unpleasant position for
black this is one of the example lines
obviously and of course black can go so
for something like happened in the in
the line that we just discussed with
passive defense this this you know like
black and also wait like this and before
you know as we discussed this is
probably just lost that's why I was
conscious discussion they say that white
is nearly or should be winning here but
after it be six there is also
alternative which is rook AAA and this
is what never played but this of course
is decided as warfare shot definitely
because let's say if King g7 right now
after King g7 there is move for instance
both kinky one and the king I mean first
of all I can go for the same same thing
so this is basically just winning like
if let's say idea King the king he
walking the two authorities before why I
can go for the same thing but the idea
of a violist play rugby it and like okay
if you go route a seven it seems like we
are just repeating position and it's
just just you know draw however if you
go rook a six suddenly my king is just
joining to the king side this would
happen in the game finally and we all
managed to get his King back to the quiz
is not easy anymore
but therefore I was definitely suggest
playing a look at Rock a seven and going
transferring to the position which we
discussed earlier however after being it
is extremely instructive right now
because angels claims suddenly both
neural network as easier and stuff like
that and stockfish normal engines that
right now rook takes ba twins engines
claim that and I was curious about it
like is it is it really winning takes
takes right okay what takes the pawn
right and seems like you know what could
be wrong with it it seems like it's just
winning and angels claim that this wing
as well so the question is what about
dr. Bishop we should be five and at
first I was thinking that you know okay
energies can be wrong right like because
the avulsions plus two or something so
it's quite a lot and I was really
wondering and they were agreeing but
they were basically
saying it like agreeing about the
evaluation which is interesting because
you know usually if one one confirms the
other should be really winning so I was
but I was curious isn't really winning
so here white has to moves 90 X B 5 or C
3 let's first see what happens after C 3
because L C zero claims that this is
just crushing there's a plus two and
came over and this is actually a draw
and this is concept of four threads
which even LC 0 sometimes first fails to
understand we should take C 4 C takes d4
and now King g7 and this is just
fortress basically black plays at five
King f6 draw there is no of course the
white king comes to a four this is just
draw there is no any breakthrough
everything is just blocked there is no
breakthrough there is extra pawn true
but this one doesn't matter let's say
kinky to f5 kinky freaking of six King
a4 and just wait Bishop f7 we should be
a fast time we should be six draw there
is no no breakthrough I tried you know
play few moves here but like without any
particular success it's just just a draw
in my pian I didn't see any break flow
so after C free and also another line
let's say in this position if the King
goes through d2 to the Queen side
Kingdom just come to c6 and black just a
swish of the seven Bishop e6 b should be
saying we should be six again no break
from simply no break from black can't
just wait like like this if it comes
King comes to be it so what we shall be
seven King doesn't go any more anywhere
further everything is covered and is a
fortress with a draw so C free even
though it's claimed by engine this wind
is actually it's to a draw compares the
symplast sometimes don't understand the
concept of fortress so Knight XB v I
came to ago [ __ ] has to be tried but
Bishop takes b2 this simplifies the
position again and right now pair of
bishops I was thinking whether here in
this position pair of bishops can
actually give some hopes for a draw and
in my opinion it not only gives hopes
for a draw but nearly guarantee is a
draw and
this is maybe a bold claim to make but I
truly believe that so let's have a kinky
to analyze and we should be seven very
important move and I believe that this
is should be a draw because let's after
ninety seven D 495 this was all those
best moves by engines and everything
else was just almost nothing almost no
advantage kinky five right now only move
if King g7 I the for simply wins so we
need to play actively in a kinky five
and right now the best move was night to
be six trying to hit this Bishop I
trying to hit this Bishop on d7 and and
pollen f7 and also night c4 so like
multi-purpose move sim I thought this
should be somehow winning right now I'm
thinking what after what happened after
night of for this also seems like
possible but on the other hand it seems
like black will have good compensation
if we activate this Bishop somehow
however I am not entirely sure right now
so this could be also try we should see
one maybe not h5 to be honest not sure
to be one is not not not so sure so
maybe this was my bed right now in this
position I didn't concern at the fore I
just kind of like one by one i b6 but
neither for it could be it could be an
interesting try definitely was white
could try here to win this because I
thought 9b was very good but Bishop e6
night c4 and night after night c4 Bishop
takes c4 because the thing is if by
white text is the black just takes and I
don't think there is enough to win this
is blocked on the Queen side and I've
done I don't think that there is enough
for white to win this also because the
pawns on the Queen side actually right
now it's good that they're like h5 which
for our black pawns and white pawns are
on the dark squares because most pawns
could be objective of the attack and
easier to let's say challenge them
four and so on so here ninety-four fo
and this bit of text e4 and I write I'm
detective for and I thought this was
amazing resource for white basically
because of what was right now on h5g for
and f7 most poems would be easily
attacked and very likely collected but
after a bishop a three c5 and f5s a c6
King d6 just going after his pawn bishop
d5 and right now let's say just King c7
I don't see any progress here provide
which is sort of crazy because seems
like almost posed on the quiz that are
following but there is no way to
actually make a good use of it for
instance king of one I thought it was
crushing because King comes to g2 for
instance f3 is also possible and the
thing is okay first thing which ff7 is
not so great because after this the King
comes to the if I was simply a draw cube
covers a5
no no discussion just draw so we took
somehow create some you know make sure
that we attack those pawns like that of
course black wants play for and if black
plays a four tries to simplify the
position this basically blacks idea
defensive idea so we need to attack
white pawns so we need to make sure that
our posts are just sort of so that's why
King f1 King give one a four and right
now King g2 we to make sure that this
structure is quite solid if they HD free
F takes G free but right I'll be shot
before and yes
right now we can just collect these
pawns but this position again I think is
drawn which maybe it's maybe some sort
of crazy maybe sounds crazy but it is so
I don't see any way to improve this
position and let's see why we shall be
to let's say we should be one should be
freaking g5 can get free Bishop d2 for
instance all the natural moves by white
however what you do next if G folders
always be shop you on and attacks the
pawn on h4 right and this one which for
its attacked
black way to display h5 then Bishop g5
points are blocked or there is no way to
improve with white is simply a draw so
let's save King comes to h3 I thought
but okay we should lead to same thing
and after it's for King f4
h5 of course kini g5 blocking all the
pawns and that's it the only attempt for
white to play it would be g5 and right
now black has only moved by its
efficient mission before the idea is to
play DC's Bishop f8 and this is simply
simply a draw so this is not winning
this is not winning only think I'm a
little bit concerned about right now
it's a little bit earlier he in this
position Knight f4 which is the move I
didn't consider in my analysis I mean
this again is quite extensive so I kind
of missed it but probably it's by some
reason not so great because I don't
think that engines would make such a
mistake of missing either for however
you never know a vengeance so possibly I
made a mistake here and I didn't
consider the fork which could be it
could be giving good chances so
definitely worth to work analyzing and I
will make sure
maybe next time when I do the this
analysis I say in the end game which
would be next week I will come back to
this position and I'll discuss it in
detail for further so in this position
because I just discovered right now
while discussing it this game so just
just you know things you learn so blue
k-6 happen in the game and therefore you
know right now King g7 is already not so
easy after King g7 I think position is
already it's very hard to make progress
because the king is joining the King to
the Queen side so after Kinki one King
de 7 this what happened the game is
let's say here sorry this position I
have four would happen as we already
know wind our palm before for it twist
position position to work and the robot
c5 comes in and it's not easy to make a
progress right this we discuss very
similar position would we just discuss
like five minutes ago so this is not so
easy and if we shop a - there's always
rook c8 counter-attack on the c2 upon so
it's not easy to put this problem before
so never played rook King b1 which is a
logical move but king is a king d7 King
comes again to the
with kinetic queenside I've been on the
queenside is the idea of before is
already not so great because there's
idea of Bishop d6 pawn before will be
attacked it's not so easy anymore so
never played neither four takes takes
and right now after working seven Ruby
it was possibly even more accurate after
compiling for King c7 f5 Bishop a5
Bishop takes d5 suddenly position gets
in that simplified regalia kindy to be
should be six and I think this is
already not enough to to win its
position with white most importantly
there was trade d5 point for the g3 pond
and the or f4 pond but basically it did
this exchange this trade simply favors
black right now black also has pawn
majority on the quiz on the King side is
possible to create a passed pawn so
there is definitely some counter play
for for black and the game happened in
the game hub you should take C six I
checked alternatives they don't give
anything that for instance just show one
of them Bishop g2 just g3 is a very nice
move
after takes Bishop g4 move a rookie to
idea we should have one right now a5
very strong move and the idea is simply
rookie free and the black has I believe
enough compensation here to to make a
draw even though this temporary pawn
down with rookie free coming there I
think black has enough compensation here
so they can happen here Bishop takes me
six after takes the game simply ended in
a draw there's not who didn't happen
much just repetition and they came in
the under the draw so it was very
interesting endgame but the most
important thing is that in such n games
you have to basically play slowly you
can rush things and to always watch out
for opens counter play and with Reuben
a7 envious counter play is fully
contained because the king is kind of
the king is not coming to the Queen side
and we have clear idea of winning of
King one kindy two or kinky one wish
away to before we should be free and
then a king our K our King comes back
and then neither for it basically is
just simply winning for for white as we
discussed so this will bid for this game
and we'll discuss next one
hopefully we can finish it in time it's
also quite extensive so I'll probably
will have to go quite quickly through it
but anyway I think hold on a second we
should be able to finish it so this is
my game against first of bullski my
friend from Poland in 2013 I want to
start actually with this position why it
was so like ok
okay
[Music]
okay
okay so basically this endgame just kind
of like yeah this is the position and
talked about and in this position
basically white has small edge but it's
basically not not enough in general to
to actually do anything positions around
equal obviously why why black would be
worse like you know everything is like
Queens are traded you know there are no
any significant weaknesses the roots
will be likely at least one of them will
be likely traded on the D file no any
reasons no any really reasons to worry
here for for black however I decided to
play on and play I played a for King f8
all those moves are pretty natural be
free to Ruby g7 is all good bringing the
king club it closer group d88 xp5 rook
tasty one and right now pretty important
move Knight XD 191 is important because
the knight is headed to d3 square and on
d3 is the ideal spot for this night and
be worried supports both Queen side play
and and life let's say in the center
through f4 so and it can happen it takes
be five seed a prefab was also possible
what ethics because is also okay night
of 297 93 Bishop f7f for finally I
decide to play a four in order to create
some play in the in a cellar
it takes a fortnight X of four rook e8
Bishop d3 and right now position still
equal and in my opinion the easiest path
to equality was right now to go for
simplifications actively very
dynamically by playing c5 and over the
next c4 and I will see any here problems
any problems q4 for block and possibly
the game will have Justin draw I don't
seem like a probably probably just
arrived is just a draw so the idea is
that let's say if King C free or
something at c4 and we just tried
everything and you know just just
just equal also I have to be quite
careful not to lose lose a piece in this
line so probably after this if I would
play 95 and or maybe take on f6 the 95
tried to try the e5 e 4.4 let's say this
this try to trade this point if 4.4 be 5
pawn for instance takes takes takes the
wouldn't play this position but it's
just roughly equal position so vitamin D
stick which is also ok 96 route 86 King
C free and right but right now should've
made a mistake he played rookie 5 and I
believe that after Ruby 5 I have certain
chances to it the correct move was again
to play c5 it was basically essential to
try to play this move because if he
doesn't do it after Ruby 5 before this
is what happened the game and I think
this is already better for white because
pawn pawns on c6 and if I are fixed and
I have little more space and potentially
pawn physics could be a weakness also
upon f6 could be potentially a weakness
so there are certain ideas here for for
white and the objectively positions
should be somehow defendable but I need
I have some practical chances so in this
position the simplest was c5 again we
see 5 let's say G takes of 60 takes of 6
Ruby 1 or something let's say B for King
D - Bishop g6 King III King g7 let's say
one example line rookie 5 right now
everything is nicely protected point c5
is not a weakness
every pawn on C - you know could be
considered as sort of another way a
weakness but like it's on light squares
so in the very distant improbable still
but future poncey - could be the object
of the attack by the light score black
bishop so ok 1 let's say I don't see
objectively just a composition I don't
see any improvement here for white
position just you know around it
it's clearly better than what up in the
game because as we get to this structure
right now h6 14 some trades King before
King g7 as you see those bonds are in
light squares so potentially there could
be attacked by my bishop potentially of
course but the thing is it's not easy to
make a progress here with white because
the drug is very active on e5 and always
there is component of the rook h5
anything in this point so I can't
activate my rook
- let's say hey they'd say quickly after
that I cannot do this because after Luke
age five I really have to come back
therefore I have to defend this pawn I
had to come up with some ideas let's say
to try to bring my activate my roof so I
played through day let's say the F I'll
supply Bishop e2 King D six right now
okay won't be possible obviously but the
same Bishop h5 I want to go into detail
here because Bishop h5 I want to go into
dinner because we I want to show the
entire game and most important points
multiple ideas because there was lots of
maneuvering back and forth and you know
it's not it's not quite important the
only thing important thing is that after
which seven I can do it because we reach
5 and therefore ideally I want out I'll
say this ideally I want my opponent's
pawn to be on h5 I want to provoke this
pawn to go to h5 that polo h5 because
with pollen h5 this rook can go to h5
Square and attack my pawn this is the
very important concept that I had in
mind
entire game I remember so I have to do
it somehow in order you know to win I
have to achieve some of this goal
approaching he spun to go to 85 and
therefore I played Ruby g8 we should
have 7 I was lots of maneuvering back
and forth no really important no it's
not really quite important you know just
maneuvering shuffling pieces back and
forth trying to maybe gain some time
maybe try to create some ideas trying to
find some ideas it's typical it's a
strategy to do it but in general in this
position finally I stopped taking g3
and the idea of king he freeze that I
realized the move king of before I can
actually activate my rock I had to bring
my king to f4 in order to active in my
rock because if then I rock h5 happens I
have always King G free
protecting my palm so it was at least
interesting a practical attempt and
right now it looks h5s all correct -
raaga for ruby 5 rogue f1 rook age 5 and
now look each one ideas to play King F 4
and then kini g3 and then rook a 1 and
rogue a 7
still nothing nothing terrible King F 4
and of course if Rukh a one right now
rogue age 5 so I've taking a 4 first and
this is actually the very important
position because it was right now that
one of the maybe even only moment were
actually apart from that we know at the
beginning of the positive disposition I
played before I think it was the only
moment where my wooden shoe stuff could
have played moves c5 if c5 this is quite
important because he creates some
counter play and it's not right now
simple for me to make any progress for
instance after c3 trying to make make
sure that pawn b5 is a weakness with
tried am Bishop c4 for instance and
against the active defense if Bishop see
- if we don't trade bishops rookie six
rook is against big getting activated
raga is six or rub d6 coming to a second
rank
maybe to d4 trying to a no idea it may
be to a six to eight - and attack before
pawn maybe just activate you know just
activity go for counter play Rudy six
King e6 the say okay eight King g5 h 5 I
was thinking maybe row gauge I to a row
page six but right now we just rotate
six row gauge six book a free of course
is an example line but basically this is
what black should aim for when the fine
is at position go look for maximum
activity of own pieces and look right
now black sacrifice a pawn but these are
extremely active and basically it should
be a draw for instance I here I finish
my another analysis because I don't see
actually how to improve the position
further on so this should this would be
a draw for instance like this if we shop
c4 already the best defense in visual C
for I take this pawn a look see one
simile I'm winning upon right
but how to make a prog from academic
progress in this position I don't see a
way to make a progress here
for instance Kim de frutas rookie 5 Ruby
just stays in place even working comes a
little bit closer to the queenside rogue
age five King goes back group if I broke
b5 I don't see any progress here
possible Roxy for us to go back right
now I don't see anything here I think
it's just a draw so c5 was the last
moment and probably only moment where he
could have done that because after
Bishop d6 probably hidden realize it's
the danger that exists in this position
and with making on f4 because I right
after rook g1 again maneuvering group a1
funny my route comes to the Queen side
and can actually join the kind of like
provoke some weaknesses so after Luke a1
king b6 right this this rogue a
seven-run a rogue age 5 and of course I
have let's say this first
the now King G for my king is actually
covering this h4 pawn and it's not easy
to actually play over this position
right now anymore
rook GA it could be some threat already
so here to come back
I played rogue h7 and suddenly I'm
forcing to him to play h5 exactly what I
wanted it's my entire plan or when I'm
playing the king he freakin a for
exactly provoke h5 in order to make this
pawn to be there right now
lukkage fire is not not a concern
anymore and attack this fall so my rock
and stay active I can maybe bring my
king to a d4 a call so maybe attack a
6-point somehow suddenly there are
weaknesses for black that is not easy to
defend
it's definitely a huge achievement for
me right now so in this position he play
kingly six one of the possible
approaches to defend explosion BC 5 + c4
try to block a block everything but I
don't think that for me not just example
I don't think the black has enough
defensive resources if I can bring my
bishop to f5 should we just winning
however if we place kinky sex is all
correct
here I come up I see free immediately
and this is what I didn't didn't do
please Seyfried and what is bishop see
to be should be free Sammis Bishop joins
the game from this diagonal from this
angle and a row gauge six also is a big
threat sometimes I can consider going
for also rook and games however of
course I'll rather keep as many pieces
as possible on the on the board because
to keep the position quite complex for
my opponent to you know to make decision
decision made my decision making very
difficult at least from practical point
of view so King the six which is seven
for instance this is this and again
let's say some amount some as it goes on
Bishop c6 Bishop the three we showed the
0k6 King v7 let's say this and finally
let's say c4 in this position is a
little bit better to achieve that
because if Bishop is already on this
diagonal and can protect the say Bishop
going to h3 oh sorry shall we try
obviously however let's say if I anyway
can bring it this Bishop somehow the say
King goes here
sorry not not this rogue a7 first Bishop
g2 and put some pressure like this
suddenly sometimes wish up a free could
be even winning this could be easily
winning because after takes takes King
g6 king of four and suddenly at some
point there will be some sort of tux
funk for instance here trying to
outmaneuver our I mean my opponent Luke
h7 this is already sort of a tubes funk
because after King the king if I tear up
d7 if y the real group gets to defile
comfortably for the seventh rank is dog
came over because rock d5 goes in and
that's it
so if King the a rogue f7 Ruby six Ruby
seven hitting the spot and suddenly Ruby
six kinky seventy rook c6 this was
analyzed and if King of seven only moved
the King because Ruby 65 which just
means the game
so after is the room d6 and I Rock d5 it
just came over it of course yeah pretty
much it just came over so this is very
difficult position for for black this
was C free was probably just much more
accurate however a player gate seven I
didn't see a need to do it which is also
pretty good cop because position but
brackets back has no counter play
anywhere whenever there is c5 there is C
free and this doesn't solve any problems
it was one comfortable one comfortable
one when that cool yet but not this
moment is gone it's not it's not there
anymore so please just okay one who just
you know regrouping pieces back and
forth anyway it was moved numbers right
now 75 I was we were bobbing time
trouble right now even though it seems
like moves are simple but you know it's
been a long game and definitely the time
the you know being playing on increment
right now deafened doesn't help
but anyway it's much easier for me to
make a move than my opponent Ruby 6r
okay won a king g6 bouquet 600 muru goes
back to the a file and after rook F 7 3
7 finally I realized that I have to go
for c3 and I found this idea of mission
c2 Bishop b3 and this is simply over and
I could have could have done it earlier
I donated in this position actually I'd
managed witness position which is even
better than the previous one because
right now there's c5 doesn't even exist
because my king on d4 you know covers
the c5 square certified is not possible
anymore
so after C freeze just came over because
which was C to B shall be free comes and
also look f7 I have so f6 pawn Falls so
my opponent like in d6 Bishop c2 ruger
Sam right now is a big fret for instance
just to just to show it is this King g6
game over so it's not it's not possible
so after c5 b takes e5 rook takes e5
finally here to do it but it's not good
anymore because right now I'll just come
back we should be free and right now
pawn beef is a weakness pawn f6 weakness
and pawn h5 s also weakness black all
black bones are weak and one of them has
to fall basically so rookie 5 rook f7
applied if King is Ruby 6 sorry I can
give free Bishop g2 he played but if we
just of played Bishop g4 I would have
played group b7 I'd say a 5 right after
rook takes b5 f takes e5 f XD for Bishop
takes before it was just an extra pawn
and very likely it is winning because
pollen h5 is still a weakness and with
extra pawn which can be supported world
by the King Bishop and rope
I think this is simply game over
of course we shouldn't be trading groups
because there is this kind of thing that
this pawn on h4 is kind of like on the
on the edge of the basically for
instance if we do this we should trade
drugs but if we trade rooks this could
be sometimes a draw because this endgame
would be pretty much immediate draw
right because there is a wrong square
for this for this Bishop this call blind
Bishop or something right so this is
just a dress only curve only thing that
we have to be careful about but normally
even we don't trade rooks and be a
little careful we should win this with
white so in this position interest of a
Bishop g2 after right now King goes back
I want to note one thing how I does I
made a king de for kinky freaking a for
and then kinky freaking de for back and
then again to f4 like so many times
right and basically it's sort of a
technique to do not hurry basically and
slowly no cost some more and more
weaknesses and the game happened a game
game and actually quite quickly because
the Queens Kings if I suddenly is not
possible to defend this pawn on h5 as I
said like one of those pawns would fall
if Bishop would retreat to is the
position to g4 pond b5 falls room b7 if
Bishop retreats g2h 5-point falls so one
of them will fall either way in rookie v
rook h6 and f6 bone Falls there are so
many weaknesses
Bishop e3 rook f6 and this is just game
of rocky 8 through g6 rouga fate rest
doesn't require much commentary
basically it's just pretty
straightforward and 2 extra pounds of
rock n game two extra pawns here just of
resigned and this move 100 since
basically the endgame was 80 moves like
many went through this game quite
quickly but I just the first one was
also very is interesting there were lots
of interesting moments and I want to
cover both of them so in this position
I went quite quickly but anyway I want
to I think I managed to point out all
the important things that I wanted to
and just if I if I want to do if I
wanted a small recap of what happened
for tool actually free things first
thing do not hurry one this is the rule
in such end games that's basically
extremely important and vulnerable
because this position this structure is
moved number 35 and we played and
disposed this pawn structure we've pond
I mean considering pwnage five as well
changed in move number pretty much
around move 8090 actually move ninety I
to the spawn so basically it took me
fifty five moves to change to actually
win upon here fifty five moves okay if I
will he played c5 which is basically
maybe it's less but let's say 40 50
moves in order to let's say most make
some changes in the position from moved
up from this position so this is the
thing do not hurry
second thing weaknesses try to create
weaknesses on try to Bob from Bob and
from quick squeeze I like inside and you
know maybe something you know eventually
will work and third think control opens
counter play and the luggage fires
runner only counter play but after I
managed to somehow bring my rook to
start King to f4 and then my look to h7
he was forced to play h5 right so this
is another thing control opens Condor
play and come up with your own ideas so
this is I think all for for this class I
think this was I mean I know this was
lots of material and maybe I went over
especially the last game quite quickly
but anyway I think it's really worth it
because it's just I think such complex
and games are
how often quite quite happen quite often
and important to know how to play them
that's why I wanted to talk about them
and probably next time when we do in the
next lecture inside game I'll cover more
of such endgame is because I think is
just sort of unlimited topic to talk
about and from various angles from
various perspectives like the first one
was with this different structure and
nefesh G and V L was different structure
this one's also different pawn structure
different pieces and it's sort of
unlimited topic to talk about so I think
and it's all something is very
interesting so probably we're going to
talk about this the next next time as
well so thank you for today I hope it
was interesting and instructive and see
you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you